uh okay so you just put up a video today
about um was it today about Math Hoffa
yeah I mean yeah well I saw I so I I
don't really all I saw was I think last
week
he had posted your guys's DMS was that
the case am I on this
I mean and then he pretty much was like
Hey guys if I don't hit you back you
know whatever whatever but he happened
to use your DMs as an example right
um and then I mean there was more to it
but
um I mean it's all over the internet I
don't want to keep on talking about him
and being a dead horse right but I will
say this well you posted a video today
no it was yesterday it was yesterday
okay I posted a video but he me and him
went live okay okay okay so after that
live I'm like you know what I'm saying I
don't want to keep on going on a whole
tour about it right right but I will say
this
I will say this
um
I was fooled
you know I mean okay you got it I was
fooled I I didn't know that he was
acting this whole time I didn't know
that he had a costume on because that's
basically what he said on the live
because I was like oh you a street dude
you know what I'm saying and he was I
was like yo Street dudes ain't supposed
to have a uh somebody with a somebody on
a show talking about an active murder
case you know what I'm saying so um no
Street dude would do that and he was I'm
not a street dude okay you know what I'm
saying and and and and so when I met him
I met him a while ago you know I mean
and I was just under the assumption that
we came from the same cloth and came
from the same like more rules and and
and you know what I'm saying the
principles like you know what I'm saying
so now now he showed himself yesterday
on the live he said that's not what he
he's not from that and that's not what
he rep like that's not he he he that's
not what it is but when I first met him
that's what it was that's what he said
he was right so so you know my bad I
didn't know that you that he had a
costume on and a lot of people is uh see
you know what it is people do things and
they carry certain they carry certain uh
uh uh morals and principles when it's
convenient for them you understand what
I'm saying and now since it's not really
that convenient they just take it off
and it just you know